what do you think bitcoin's price hits
by the end of the year we're sitting
around 50 000 right now what's what's
your end-of-year bitcoin price
prediction
let's say 100k 100k 100k yeah all right
so we go from 50 to 100k by the end of
the year yeah if bitcoin hits 100k by
the end of the year what changes in
latin america for people with bitcoin is
it just seen as an investment in people
who are holding bitcoin obviously it
appreciates they're excited uh does that
change the way that people think about
it adopted or nothing changes oh yeah
it's definitely going to continue to uh
increase trust which again trust is is
everything in any form of money
um
is going to help a lot of people that
have exposure to bitcoin and that are
not necessarily wealthy most of the
people that i love crypto and bitcoin
are like middle class and elites
but you still have a portion of people
that are uh kind of like poor uh that
have somehow adopted bitcoin so if if
that happens it will continue to take
some people out of poverty which is
awesome
um and um
and
i think that uh
what i really want to see is like at one
point at one point in time is bitcoin
gonna be um what is the floor uh of
volatility uh and if the floor of
volatility starts to reduce every time
you know there's like a bull market or a
bear market when the bear market you
know hits the bottom
if it's less of an aggressive percentage
over time it's going to be seen as a
more or less volatile
uh currency and uh in turn is going to
be used for like payments ideally with
lightning lightning network and and
those things so yeah
it feels to me like uh latin america the
statue laid out with uh the internet
penetration um just the unbanked
population and then also this like macro
tailwind of a really bad economic
situation
naturally forces people to look for
other alternatives and so whether it's
the stable coin whether it's bitcoin
just these rails this industry this
technology ends up pretty much capturing
people's imagination say yes this is the
solution yeah right yeah it's uh it's
pretty cool where can we send people to
find you on the internet
um twitter uh simon value so value is uh
v
uh a l i u
and um same on instagram
and you can log up value on
on my profile as well
and find us there
the website is in spanish i think and
all these things are in spanish but
yeah i'm putting your uh for anyone who
wants to follow him i'm putting him uh
right now in the chat his uh twitter
account so make sure you go follow him
uh and you're actually linked i think is
the slash en right yeah yen yeah they'll
get it in english rather than
than me who i type in value and i always
get it i have to remind myself that uh
yeah while i live in miami and miami is
uh uh uh arguably the actual uh language
of uh of miami um or spanish is i can't
i can't speak it so john's working on it
i'm getting closer
right yeah um all right man listen thank
you so much for doing this i think
obviously the the problem is really
really bad uh in latin america venezuela
specifically and i think there's you
know millions and millions of people who
can be helped so keep going and i'm
excited to be along for the ride thank
you man
all right good job thank you john joe
you guys got anything else nope
appreciate you coming on time what's up
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]